Україна стрімко втрачає робочу силу
і цього року стане лідером за темпами втрати трудових ресурсів.
Такий невтішний прогноз нещодавно оприлюднила
міжнародна консалтингова компанія PriceWaterhouseCoopers.
а даними аналітиків, з-поміж європейських країн,
які у 2019-му так само страждатимуть від цієї проблеми,
найближчі сусіди України - Румунія, Угорщина, Молдова, Росія та Білорусь.
Аналітики називають дві головні причини втрати Україною робочої сили -
трудову міграцію та старіння населення.
Те, що рекордно високі показники втрати трудових ресурсів
прогнозують саме у 2019-му -
результат посилення тенденцій попередніх років.
Уже нині за кордоном, за оцінками Міністерства соціальної політики,
постійно працюють 3 мільйони 200 тисяч українців,
тимчасово - від 7 до 9 мільйонів осіб.
Найчастіше українці їдуть на сезонні роботи у сільському господарстві,
на будівництво, а також працюють у сфері послуг,
ресторанному чи готельному бізнесі.
За кордоном українські заробітчани, як правило, отримують
у два-три рази вищу зарплату.
Хоча мало хто з них працює на посадах,
які відповідають їхньому рівню кваліфікації.
Одним з найбільш улюблених маршрутів українських заробітчан
є Польща, саме там українців найбільше - близько 2 мільйонів.
Загалом, за даними Євростату, у 2017 році
ця країна стала лідером у Євросоюзі
за видачею дозволів на проживання іноземцям -
700 тисяч, з них 85% - українцям-
Трудову міграцію українців спричиняють
здебільшого низькі зарплати та брак роботи.
Рівень безробіття серед економічно активного населення
торік, за даними Держстату,
склав майже дев’ять відсотків.
Тим часом самі заробітчани серед причин виїзду називають
також нестабільність в Україні, відсутність справедливої соціальної політики,
низький рівень життя і медицини.
Щодо старіння населення - то тут збігаються кілька чиників:
скорочення народжуваності на тлі зростання смертності
плюс масовий виїзд саме працездатних українців,
яких недораховується український ринок праці.
З одного боку, українці, які працюють за кордоном,
залишаються одними з головних постачальників валюти до країни.
Лише за три квартали 2018 року
заробітчани, за даними Національного банку,
переказали в Україну понад вісім мільярдів доларів.
Це помітний внесок до ВВП країни
і, здавлось би, має позитивніший вплив на стан української економіки,
ніж якби вони залишалися безробітними в Україні.
Утім, втішатися цим - короткозоро.
Адже втрата освіченої молоді та кваліфікованих спеціалістів
уповільнює економічне зростання країни,
особливо в довгостроковій перспективі.
Експерти застерігають: відтік робочої сили
матиме для України катастрофічні наслідки.
Адже країна стрімко і назавжди втрачає кваліфікованих фахівців,
яких готувала роками. Закріпившись за кордоном,
ці молоді люди перетягнуть туди також свої сім'ї.
Це призводитиме до дедалі більших фінансових втрат -
за оцінками експертів, уже тепер через відтік робочої сили
українська економіка недораховується близько 40 мільярдів гривень на рік.